hallo leute heute reden wir über die da
wörter damit darauf darüber davon was
haben all diese worte gemeinsam und wann
benutzt man sie da wörter bestehen immer
aus einem dar und einer präposition wie
an aus über mit der wärter werden immer
in kombination mit verben benutzt die
mit einer präposition benutzt werden zum
beispiel suchen nach sich erinnern
anfahren mit dass da ersetzt in einem
satz das objekt immer dann wenn das
objekt zum beispiel nicht genannt oder
nicht noch einmal wiederholt werden soll
im englischen würde man dieses da immer
mit übersetzten zum beispiel wait for it
on at schauen wir uns ein paar beispiele
an zb ich fahre mit dem fahrrad zum büro
ich fahre damit zum büro damit ersetzt
das objekt mit dem fahrrad oder ich sage
ich freue mich auf die party heute abend
ich kann auch sagen ich freue mich
darauf dass darauf er setzt auf die
partie heute abend hier ist ein
typischer fehler den ich mir vor kurzem
aufgeschrieben hat eine freundin von mir
hat gesagt sie hat nicht so viel zeit
für das zeit haben benutzt man mit für
im englischen sagt man to have time for
it aber auf deutsch
würdest du nicht dass nehmen als objekt
sondern dass da worte ich habe nicht so
viel zeit dafür
oder sie hat nicht so viel zeit dafür
das wäre der korrekte satz gucken wir
uns einen anderen fehler an
ein freund von mir hat vor kurzem gesagt
ich hatte keine ahnung von dass der
ausdruck ahnung haben wird mit fronten
aber man benutzt nicht das als objekt
ich hatte keine ahnung von das ist ein
fehler
korrekt heißt der satz ich hatte keine
ahnung davon
damit ihr das ganze besser lernen könnt
haben wir jetzt einige szenen für euch
vorbereitet
los geht's janosch interessiert sich
immer für die neuesten schlagzeilen
hast du schon davon gehört dass hell und
medienwelten adoptiert haben
nein janisch und ich interessiere mich
auch nicht dafür
janus versucht sich an meinem geburtstag
zu erinnern
verdammt ich erinnere mich nicht daran
er spielt den ganzen tag auf seiner
gitarre
ich liebe es darauf zu spielen
[Musik]
jarosch sucht nach seiner brille
ich suche schon den ganzen morgen kari
hört nicht auf herum zusammen hör auf
damit hast du was mit knoblauch gebucht
wie so riecht es hier nach knoblauch die
ganze wohnung richter nach achtmal auch
der napt ja okay ich achte darauf ein
gutes frühstück besteht aus café chips
und natürlich
[Musik]
daraus besteht das irgendwie nicht in
unserer interaktiven apps link könnt ihr
jetzt noch mehr szenen sehen und das
thema noch intensiver üben
vor einigen wochen haben wir euch die
seite schon vorgestellt ihr könnt dort
unter anderem die untertitel anklicken
ihr könnt eure eigene sprache aufnehmen
und eure aussprache mit der von
muttersprachlern vergleichen und vieles
vieles mehr
probiert es mal aus den link findet ihr
hier unter dem video und wir freuen uns
wenn sie uns nächste woche wieder sehen
hier bei easy jet skis und bis bald